شدد رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين على ان
بلاده تشهد تحديات كبيره وصعبه تمس
سيادتها مؤكدا على ضروره مواجهتها مهددا
بتكتكات جديده في اوكرانيا
روسيا تواجه اليوم تحديات كبيره وصعبه
تمسوا سيادتها ويجب التصدي لها لذلك روسيا
ممتنه لكل الجنود والضباط الذين اظهروا
شجاعه استثنائيه للدفاع عن وطنهم واداء
واجبهم العسكري في العمليه الخاصه ذلك
الواجب سيساعد في اقامه حياه طبيعيه
وسليمه للمواطنين في المناطق الجديده من
روسيا
ووصف بوتين الوضع في مناطق دوناتس
ونوجزنك لوجان
بالوضع صعب للغايه واضاف ان لدى روسيا
حاليا قدره كافيه لخلق تهديدا لاوكرانيا
والقيام باعمال تكتيكيه من بيلاروسيا
الواقعه على الحدود الشماليه
صعبه
من جديد
القوات بالاليات العسكريه والاسلحه
الحديثه
ميدانيه ذكرت سلطات دوناتس المواليه
لروسيا انا معارك عنيفه تجري حاليا في
الجهه الغربيه من مدينه مارينكه
واشارت الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت
مقاطعه دوناتس
235 قذيفه وصاروخا من 52 موقعا مختلفه في
الساعات الاخيره
من جهه الاخرى اكد مراسل العربيه ان
القوات الاوكرانيه ارسلت وحدات عسكريه الى
سوليدار في الدونات حيث لا تزالوا المعارك
دائره لسيطره على المدينه
ومعنى من ثياب مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
اهلا بك حذيفه ما هي المستجدات الميدانيه
اقله
على الكهرباء في المدن المختلفه طبعا
الضربه الاخيره اثرت بشكل كبير على محطات
الكهرباء وفي العاصمه كيف عادت الى عدد
كبير من الاحياء ولكن هنالك احياء لليوم
الثاني على التوالي لم يعد التيار
الكهربائي وتعالي ايضا من انقطاع في
التدفئه وفي المياه هذا الامر ينطبق كذلك
على عدد من
المدنسه همم بلطف وعدد من المدن الخاصه
المدن الشرقيه ايضا سومي تعاني ايضا جزئيا
من انقطاع في الكهرباء والمياه والتدفئه
اما في الوضع الميداني للحرب طبعا الخبر
اليوم هو زياره الرئيس مرسي الى جبهه ضخمه
زار الرئيس الجنود وقدم لهم جوائز الدوله
وقدم لهم علم الميداليات واطلع على
الاوضاع في الجبهه وشكر الجنود طبعا على
القتال في هذه الجبهه وهي الجبهه الاشرس
والاعنف في الصراع الروسي الاوكراني في
الوقت الحالي طبعا جبهه عريضه جدا تمتد
منها وحتى منطقه سولدار همم القوات
الروسيه شلت حوالي همم هجوم في حوالي 20
بلده متزامن اطلقت اربعه صواريخ في اتجاه
اماكن تمركز القوات الاوكرانيه قامت
بتنفيذ 50 ضربه صاروخيه من همم انظمه همم
انظمه الصواريخ المتعدده في الجبهات
المختلفه في دونيسك ايضا الوضع في لوغاز
يحتدم قال حاكم مقاطعه لوكاس قال ان الوضع
همم يعني يتحسن بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه
هنالك تقدم بطيقه على اننا نبتعد عده
كيلومترات من همم من منطقه
طبعا الان الصراع يدور حول مدينتين
صغيرتين همم تحاول القوات الاوكرانيه
الوصول اليها ولكن قال ان المسافه ما بين
القوات الاوكرانيه وبينها بين المدينتين
مزروعه بعدد كبير جدا
ما يبطي تقدم القوات همم اوكرانيه هذا
الاتجاه ولكن انه قال انه مطمئن الا انهم
سيصلون الى هاتين المدينتين القريه قريبا
حذيفه كيف تلقفت اوكرانيا لقاء الروس
وبيلاروسيا ويعني اقر رئيس الروسي بالحظات
صعبه في هذه الحرب بالنسبه لروسيا
والمناطق الخاضعه لسيطرتها ولكن يبدو ان
هناك استعدادات لخطوات تكتيكيه في الحرب
هل من مخاوف داخل اوكرانيا
العسكريه اكثر من مره وتحدث عنها الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديميرز طبعا الاستخبارات
العسكريه قالت انه في الوقت الحالي لا
يوجد مؤشر لعمليه هجوم من الاراضي الروسيه
ولكنها على الرغم من ذلك تقول انه هذا لا
يمنع انه قد يكون ذلك عمل تكتيكي لعمليه
السياح من الاراضي الخطوات العمليه التي
قامت بها قامت قامت بها وزاره الدفاع عن
الاوكرانيه اولا هي بدات في انشاء حائط
يفصل الحدود الروسيه الحدود الاوكرانيه
الفيلا الروسيه وقامت خلف هذا الجدار قام
بحفر الخنادق وقامت ايضا انشاء جداول
للمياه وكل ذلك لمنع اي تقدم من الاراضي
الفروسيه ولكن على اهم انها ارسل عدد كبير
من القوات في الحدود الروسيه البلاسيه
الاخرانيه هي ترابه الموقع وكذلك طبعا على
طول الشريط الحدود مع فلسطين شكرا
عدل